[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we
mentioned Tom and Jerry a lot on this
show it's one of the funniest cartoons
that were made they had brilliant
comedic timing and they've been ravished
more times than a dog owners leg we've
also mentioned the Wizard of Oz Island
it's one of the great movies and for a
film that's over 80 years old still
being referenced and enjoyed by all ages
it's truly the definition of the term
timeless I also love Chippendale in
Jurassic Park but just because two
things are popular doesn't mean they
belong together okay that one kind of
does but this one does it before meeting
Willy Wonka Robin Hood and Jonny Quest
alright question tears to the question
Tom and Jerry had one of the most
popular crossovers with the Wizard of Oz
so much so that even spawned a sequel
which I'm sorry to say has no headless
mom be homage
these totally unnecessary spin also have
gotten so much attention that people
started making their own random
crossovers they're almost taking on a
life of their own but this one was
arguably the most popular showing there
is for whatever reason an audience for
this so I guess it only makes sense to
take a look and see if the attention was
warranted at all is there anything of
redeemable value to this or is it the
worst what servoz adaptation since 90%
of the other ones well let's see the
crossover that launched a million
crossovers this is Tom and Jerry and The
Wizard of Oz once again they do the
classic Tom and Jerry intro mixed with
the intro of whatever movie they're
doing a crossover with because they
always go so well together yet Disney
try that too and it worked great I
[Music]
believe in America few people know these
three were really good friends as much
as Matt Stone and Trey Parker and Leo
Tolstoy you really liked mr. hankey
looks like a good voiceover cast but the
credits quickly segue into the madness
we're about to experience through most
of this for years this story has given
faithful service to cat mice go home
movie you're drunk we then see the
opening animation of our main lead go
home Dorothy you're drunk at first it
seems to run the same course as the
original Wizard of Oz except everybody
looks like a cup head boss something
you'll notice very quickly is the
animation well it looks expensive also
looks rushed everyone kind of moves like
they're on fast-forward though there's
clearly a lot of technique in the color
and line work they still never quite
move right it's oh how does one say how
shall one say director too many frames
your majesty exactly very well put I
know that sounds silly as Disney uses a
lot of frames and in between animators
but they also know how to keep them
mostly still so while they're not moving
much they still seem alive here they
look hyper alive like they want to look
natural and flowing but don't know how
to do it on such a
I'm crunch not Dorothy dear you always
get yourself into a fret over nothing
now you just help us out today and find
yourself a place where you won't get
into any trouble you know most people
don't move like this all the time always
with some sort of hand movement or
moving the head this way and talking
over and over and over because if you do
you look like you're modeling a new
collar no wonder the farms in trouble
they have a mouse for an accountant
thanks Jer these answers to everything
is always government cheese the answer
is not always government cheese for a
farm concerned about that cows sure
flexible with killing their unhatched
ones will you promise me something
promise me you'll be friends and work
together to keep an eye on Dorothy
ex-navy adding a long gay a germ a
Bay I'm sure this song will be
just as powerful here as in the original
[Music]
yeah it sounds nice but you know what's
missing excessive violence yeah no joke
all throughout the entire song Tom and
Jerry bicker fight and trip over
themselves because the song really had
no emotional weight without it it's like
the ultimate kind of meet me in st.
Louis when they drop a piano on her head
even if the violence was taken out I
don't like the way this horse is looking
at her his eyes seemed to be saying oh
yeah Dorothy I'll take you the rainbow
jollywood way up high really means but
the mean-spirited I don't think they
give her a name in this version comes to
take Toto away I love that this is
actually so rushed then not only does
she put up little to no fight keeping
him but she accidentally calls the labia
him and nobody ever fixed it you have to
admit she is rather mannish how's the
total was seen as the most dangerous
came down on the farm when there's a
bolt-on named butch that lives there too
also come on you couldn't have droopy as
toto ppyou Tom and Jerry helped rescue
toto in this version with actually some
pretty inventive slapstick and you know
where they go from here Dorothy tries
running away and comes across a fortune
teller who tells it to go back home who
will eventually end up being the wizard
in her dream or they cut all that
I guess their subconscious made up this
guy three times
[Applause]
whores actually why you here you told me
what's up with this guy I'll mend your
troubles like lemon drops so Dorothy Tom
and Jerry all get knocked out and
somehow share the exact same dream so
either this is going on or this is going
on they of course wake up in the
colorful Land of Oz as it turns out the
munchkins are pretty hardcore
bats think about that the munchkins
carry bats is the lollipop guild gonna
have to cut a bitch
this munchkin of course is Tuffy who
explains what happened to Dorothy and
you know if you never saw the Wizard of
Oz before and this was your introduction
to it how would you react to this I was
you and Dorothy came and landed on the
Wicked Witch of the East and then Glinda
the Good Witch of the North gave Dorothy
the ruby slippers the Wicked Witch of
the West showed up to take the magical
Ruby's you are insane this is all insane
and I am never doing edibles again
here's a fun game see if you can spot
any innuendo and Tuffy offers to come
with them well you're only a munchkin
okay that makes it worse so he sings
about his hmm sighs problem as Tom and
Jerry agreed to let him tag along to see
the Wizard to get some height
[Music]
you know there's something so funny just
knowing that all the other munchkins are
in their home sleeping the witches
defeated Dorothy as often they kind of
just call it a day with no more
celebrating and then they're like oh
what's all the commotion
oh other visitors from the sky okay we
did like five song numbers for that
redneck girl we are not doing this
again we'll just give it to that Easter
egg Mouse to perform with no backup I'm
busy trying to figure out why our
flowers are looking so flat maybe it's
that new fertilizer we've been using
[Applause]
[Music]
so admit it is a little funny that even
miles later Tuffy is still singing that
song and they try to shut him off but I
took of my collar when I see black crows
in an animated adaptation of an early
40s film oh wait I forgot it's Tom and
Jerry they've had years of experience
with this kind of stuff
what are you nuts no one goes that way
what do you mean lots of people go both
ways
okay the internet already has this clip
to play with I don't think we need any
more innuendos the girls give them the
wrong directions and they stumble across
a much more dangerous path tell me if
you think Tuffy's persistence to keep
going is sounding less optimistic and a
little more cultish never stray from the
path Vanessa that's right your name is
Vanessa now SMI they come across the
Wicked Witch though who finds Dorothy
and a lot of cutscenes easing on down
the road
the witch tries to figure out how to
stop them of course we know she's gonna
use the flowers to put them to sleep for
smash them into oblivion
I'll get credit that is much more of a
Tom and Jerry way of doing things it
actually makes me wish there's a little
bit more Wizard of Oz logic to this
cartoony logy because you know the witch
would be able to survive this
look it's raining our body parts I hoped
I would never see you again
I'm hoping the wizard will give me some
brains I want a heart
I made some courage and I'll todo and I
want is to get back home to Cannes
we're clip noting what was already a
heavily cliff noted story then I'm sure
to get a brain aha well I guess my noise
doesn't mean dick anymore
it shouldn't die your great tone fifl
knockoff anyway they want to be more
honest the lyrics should be this if I
only had a script my balls hurt right
they make their way to the Emerald City
look there's the penis room a little
mermaid poster and like the original
they come across a horse-drawn carriage
[Music]
unemotionally scatterbrained driver do
you trim your beard trim my beard I'm
gonna cut your head off and bury you but
yes I've never seen a horse like that
before no and never will again I fancy
I'm gonna chew it it shines purple when
it's depressed so I'm just gonna drop it
off at the swamp of sadness the people
in the city look one step away from
drinking the green kool-aid we'll see
the Wizard - once we give him our souls
ah could you put a little more hay in
the crotch area for me it gets a little
cold in Oz if you know what I'm saying
so is one of the chicks from the farm
having this dream - how does any of this
work before the which appears to
threaten them only this time she holds
the broom in a very um clips for sale
manner okay that's just funny as before
they visit the wizard and I was gonna
make a Skeletor melting into a Mars
Attacks Martian joke but the more I look
at the top of that head it's looking a
little um a tiny uh-oh how does one say
how shall one say director to clitoris
your majesty exactly very well put as in
the original they had to get the witch's
broom before the wizard will grant any
of their wishes and as before the
Scarecrow is still packing heat I love
all the things that kept out of this
version they chose that to leave in
don't worry I'll shoot him I'll fill
them with more fall from the stubble on
script what's happened to you
they took my legs off and then threw
them over there then they took my chest
out and threw it over there then they
took my penis and said they were saving
it for a lonely night tom and jerry
break loose and run into an aza gator or
is it an oz a dial I have to look at the
note let me run into a wall should I
roll the credits welcome back the witch
tries to get Dorothy slippers like in
the original but they up the zapping
powers of her slippers just a tiny bit
you know first point with this this all
is I will give credit it feels less like
a Tom and Jerry cartoon stuck in The
Wizard of Oz and more like The Wizard of
Oz stuck in a Tom and Jerry cartoon the
comedic slapstick still gets a good
chuckle every now and then do you see
that it's how long you've got to live
I'll come back for you justice those
fans run out we'll still keep it vague
how that's going to kill you but see how
it's Tom and Jerry I guess we'll just
say death by bowling ball I don't know
we get a pretty funny cameo from Butch
and droopy as the guards he still should
have been toto you could have called him
troupe that's Tom and Jerry over here
that water can kill the witch so they go
to an unguarded unlocked well on her
property
that's all levels of odd isn't that the
equivalent of like popsicles being the
only thing that can kill you and the
only secure do you have is a sticker on
your freezer that says now eating
popsicles it could kill me so keep them
out of sight I mean you know I know that
yeah that's weird but it's come on
don't be a dick come on they break in
and stop the hourglass I think it just
kind of cuts away from it if she
suddenly dies in a few moments we'll
know why they come across the guards
don't make me do my willy wonka tunnel
monologue it works for a bit but the
witch catches up with them as tom and
jerry tried to get water
Tuffy's got some rage issues he's what
angry bastard that's right a munchkin
invented scotch tape in this reality
somehow it still makes more sense than
that Franco movie ring-around-the-rosy a
pocket full of spears thought you were
pretty foxy didn't you can I really make
fun of a word for almost sounding like
another word the last to go we'll see
the first that was like five different
Tim Curry masks from the movie legend
and somehow Tim Curry was still more
feminine
[Music]
how about a little fire scarecrow you
know what never forgot that part
isn't that kind of like setting your car
on fire Tom and Jerry splash the water
on the witch though and even though it's
animated it's still shot from a distance
so you can't make out the effects that
aren't they're confusing you know the
rest they get the broom returned to the
wizard and remember that's adjusted door
from the GI Joe movie it's along the
same yeah
and they find out here was a phony the
whole time but he finds a way of giving
them the gifts they were looking for
making them realize they had them all
along some of the square roots of any
two sides of an isosceles triangle is
equal to the square root of the
remaining side still a right triangle if
it gotta be dummy you might as well be
smart look he even gave Tuffy some
stilts do I even need to say anything
the balloon takes off without Dorothy
but he says he can't bring it back
because he doesn't know how it works how
the hell is he gonna get her home then
questions but Glenda appears via Hawking
bubbles can you send me home you don't
need to be helped any longer you've
always had the power to go back to
Kansas am I the only one that thinks
they look like Peter Lorre caricatures
and drag can you send me home
Celia forth you always handy power to go
back to Kansas Rick she taps her heels
three times ends up back home and it was
all a bad dreams yeah plural plural bad
dreams
you've just had a bad dream the local
habitation if it was a dream how a mouse
and dogs still talking and what is that
horse looking at me
can wish up all my stuff Tom and Jerry
believed Dorothy story though and tried
to act out that they went through it too
and if you didn't know the story they
were acting out you look at them like
someone lobotomized your best friend -
Tom and Jerry meet awkward silence
something happened they'd fight some
more the end credits roll and everybody
who never heard of The Wizard of Oz
thinks they're stoned out of their minds
so there it is Tom and Jerry and The
Wizard of Oz and awful Wizard of Oz
adaptation but Tom and Jerry cartoon the
special is forgivingly short clocking in
at under an hour it focuses more on
trying to tell a funny Tom and Jerry
adventure rather than a faithful Wizard
of Oz adventure and when it does that
surprisingly alright the slapstick has
an understanding of making them feel
solid so the pain seems harsher and
funnier Tom screams sound eerily close
to his original scream
and the timing for the most part is
pretty damn good where it fails not
surprisingly is the Wizard of Oz it's
just not a good adaptation because most
of what made the story so special is
kept in the background but that's kind
of what makes it an amusing Tom and
Jerry special there's not much focus on
The Wizard of Oz especially when
compared to something like the Willy
Wonka crossover so yeah I guess it's not
good as it is pointless and the Oz stuff
falls flat but it still got a few laughs
out of which after this is a ton more
than what I was expecting so it's not
technically good but it's not nearly as
bad as you would think take it for what
it's worth and find out if this acid
trip over the rainbow is for you and we
can hope there won't be any more random
crossovers from what the hell are you
doing at OU Barbera I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember esily ones are there
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out Helen Keller International is
this week's charity Helen Keller
International saves and improves the
sight in lives of the world's vulnerable
by combating the causes and consequences
of blindness poor health and
malnutrition they envision a world where
no one suffers from preventable or
treatable blindness or low vision no one
suffers from malnutrition and fewer
people suffer laws of they're productive
years due to disability and premature
death to accomplish this they build a
capacity of local government nonprofit
and private sector systems promoting the
development of sustained large-scale
programs that deliver effective
solutions to preventable blindness and
malnutrition if you look at their
website you can not only see all the
places they travel to but also all the
good people they help at those places
making sure they live good prosperous
lives click on the link and see what you
can do to help so many
[Music]
you